well developing at noon rapper travis
scott is pulling out of this weekend's
day in vegas festival the music festival
here in the valley he was on stage in
houston friday night when a crowd surge
at that festival killed at least eight
people lilia luciano reports
cell phone video shows a panicked
festival goer at friday night's asteroid
concert pleading for help from a camera
operator but the show would go on
authorities say when scott took the
stage at approximately 9 pm the crowd of
more than 50 000 rushed forward
people began passing out in the crush
video shows first responders treating
the injured but authorities say they
were overwhelmed
by the end of the night at least eight
people would die with more than a dozen
hospitalized in scores injured as the
crowd surge spun out of control
kayla jay was there and says she tried
to shield a man who had fallen to the
ground but she now fears he's among the
dead i just held his hand until like
until like he like he let go
roughly half an hour after the show
started it was declared a mass casualty
event later on scott stopped his set to
help someone in the crowd but started
again soon after his show didn't end
until about 10 10 pm almost 40 minutes
after the mass casualty event had been
declared
on saturday houston chief of police troy
finner defended the decision we have to
worry about riding riots it was a
cooperation and discussion between
promoters
my fire department the police department
scott posted this video on instagram the
next day saying he was unaware of the
severity of the situation in the crowd
i'm honestly just devastated and
i could never imagine anything like this
just
happening but some survivors say
authorities did not do enough like basil
bake he was at the festival with his
brother donish who was killed in the
crowd he got lost in the crew i looked
over my shoulder he was there once again
he did not deserve this he did not
deserve this he did not deserve this
okay both scott and the concert
promoters at live nation say they've
been cooperating with local authorities
and now police say their narcotics unit
became involved after a security guard
alleged that he was pricked on the neck
with a needle and had to be resuscitated
with narcan however at this point
there's no evidence to indicate that
that incident had anything to do or
triggered the deadly crowd surge
luciano cbs news houston